big love so pumped alright alright so we
were just talking about how you had been
circling nine thousand times since you
started yeah like I calculated about
four years ago and it was like up to six
thousand then so I imagine it's
something like eight nine thousand who
knows maybe she doesn't crazy and it's
great to have you back guy and Alex you
guys are meeting for the first time yeah
you guys were just kickin it off and
chatting so go ahead and take it back
off from where you were yeah I think you
had asked you had asked what's who is
the most interesting person you've ever
circled and so I just that's why I was
talking about the number I'm like man
there's been a lot of people so I don't
have anybody that stands out and I think
part part of the reason is actually
because I don't think I don't think it's
like the most interesting person would
be the most obvious ly interesting
person a circle
people are just interesting like people
believe the strangest things and see
things and hear things in ways that I
wouldn't have ever expected and that's
kind of the thing about circling is
developing a listening for or like to
see people as a legitimate and in their
and themselves versus kind of it as a
means to an end so you just start to you
give people that kind of space and
who-who kind of unfolds in front of you
is I've been so moved and like stunned
and horrified and surprised at who
people are and I would I would I would
specially say that the thing that seems
to be where I've been the most
contributed in learning how to circle
for these years is watching how deeply
courageous people are like people are
just when you when you really just open
have anybody talk about their life right
like it takes something to survive right
and and it takes inevitably you start to
see that
people become who they are through doing
things that are difficult and scary and
they take a lot of courage and so I I
would say that I've been deeply moved
and stunned by how courageous people
have been Rea and it's surprising yeah
so that's what I would say right like so
I'm like for example I'm listening to
you like this is the first time we've
met and so just just listening to you I
could just tell there are just random
things that you've said that I'm like
whoa you've had quite a life and you see
things probably in a way and an index
your life in a way and have an
intelligibility to that that's really
probably pretty foreign to me did I bet
like if we opened up opened you up
I would I would learn a ton about you
and I would learn a ton about life
somehow in that let's open Alex up yeah
totally then certainly you the kind of
doing in the group or the done 101 well
I would say that it's a well it can be
done in a group or it can be done
one-on-one I would say most most of the
time when people think about circling
it's it's practiced as a group most of
the time but as a the principles in as a
way of being is really designed you
could say that that's what makes circle
and kind of interesting is that there's
not very many things that are
specifically about the fundamental unit
of relationship right which is just the
ivao encounter right there's lots of
things about you know work relationships
and different forms of communication and
like romantic relationships but circling
happens to be just something that's it's
like a yoga practice on the fundamental
deep stretches under or asanas that that
go into relating and so really people do
what I think
although the you know the rationalist
community and some of the some of the AI
people and stuff like that I think they
have different reasons for doing it but
but I think mostly people do it to kind
of just like you do yoga it's not to
really get good at Yoga right like it's
so that when you're
walking around in your life now thinking
about yoga you just respond with more
balance and more openness and you know
more strength in your body so I think
certain lot of people the reason why
they do circling is is not to get good
at it but like so that when they talk to
their mother you know you know rather
than like respond to irritating way they
get interested right things like that
circling permeates into every other
aspect of our lives you know yeah cuz I
it seems like we're we're in it like
we're intersubjectivity through and
through all the way down right so like
so much of our nervous system is all
about being able to like be coordinated
socially like everything that we're
sitting inside of on some level has come
out of some kind of conversation so if
you can make a difference at that at the
fundamental the fundamental a ship and
intersubjectivity get comfortable at it
be comfortable in your own skin you know
exercise courage like lean into conflict
without closing off to the other person
all those kinds of things those are the
kinds of things that have made our
entire world right so do you do you ever
ask people what their attempts about at
any given moment or what they're anxious
about or where the most difficult is in
their maker with their hundred through
many men meaning about about right now
yeah aren't those integral part part a
questions to ask yeah yes like the the
we say that the the practice of circling
is like fundamentally it's very simple
it's like we're just being with what is
and so oftentimes people are anxious
about things and are in acting from
acting from that anxiety with having no
aware awareness of it so a lot of times
a lot of times somebody will point
something out and then like inquire
about about you and maybe they'll ask
whether or not you're anxious or not but
then yeah I'm gonna look like oh oh I'm
actually anxious fact I've been anxious
for 47 years and I've never even
realized it you know yeah
so I was never given the space to unpack
ones feelings yeah yeah that needs to
change
good oh that's a big one total living
people space to be with who they've been
and who they are really authentically
right and having people that actually
care sitting across from them asking
them those deep questions haven't you
like considered like circling with
someone while not since Satan ISIL Eve's
face the rather in their home or in a
place that can access all the previous
memories or also circling with someone
Wow it's while showing them a very
stimulating environment studies from a
library or showing them the Prada
product catalog or showing them the
PlayStation 4 three catalogue or their
or a computer adaptive with their Steam
library of all the favorite games or web
let's say all the other favorite URLs
yeah totally
well we're aware I've experienced that I
would say in the most concentrated way
is what I was talking about before where
I've been hired to come in circle with
families right and so like a family will
hire me as a coach but basically I'm
circling right that's all I really know
how to do and I'll go and I'll go and
embed myself in the family and live with
them for a couple of weeks and in that
case so for example getting to know the
kids right is that like you don't sit
down and just basically kind of go hey
tell me about your feelings they have no
idea what you're talking about but where
you connect with them is through what
they're interested in
so I've like learned videogames like and
learn how to like play GI Joes and know
learn all the names through getting to
know them but the thing about circling
is I think that things that people don't
even realize that there's a whole world
that's so then that world determines so
many things which is the recognition of
the inner subjective space right and in
its in its a space that most like most
human conversations have a an aboutness
to it so it's like is triangular in that
sense it's like there's me there's you
and then there was what we're talking
about then there's a whole and usually
that the the
the the me you connection right gets
sublimated through that connection right
like there's a whole connection being
made but it's it's never becomes the
topic of what we're talking about when
you kick off the kick out the leg of the
about and then you just touch into the
immediate space right here a lot of
people feel the sense of aliveness and
trip enos and like mmm you can evoke a
lot of anxiety but can also be the the
space of a lot of intimacy so a lot of
circling is one introducing people to
that there's such a space like so many
times people have had billions of
conversations but they've never had one
where we were like hey what's going on
right now with us mm-hmm
what we usually fight like that but we
don't really like mm-hmm actually kind
of touch in and go huh like how am i
affecting you how are you affecting me
like are we good are you anxious do you
feel like you want to like it's quite
high openness and high vulnerability
yeah to be able to do that because we
put up walls to prevent ourselves from
having that exact conversation yeah
absolutely that one's so important such
a good wood
therefore when you when people start to
circle just by getting present to what
so it also if you really look kind of
look into your own life most of people's
deep hurts and trauma like have to do
with other people right there they have
to do with betrayals and relationships
like places where they felt that they've
let someone down or they've been let
down right like some kind of affront to
like this this bond here most traumas
have to do with that when somebody that
loves us like abuses us right like so if
you start to get present to like what's
right here right now and it has to do
with relationships oftentimes what ends
up coming up is a lot of the stuff that
they talk about in therapy
all those circling isn't therapy it's
not designed to heal any anything but
just by getting present to our
relationships and how we relate it's
linked to all those things to a lot of
times those things start coming up so it
can be really healing and that's
and you know lots of Tears lots of
emotions being invited out like
whatever's there are you constantly
tapping into what guy is talking about
with other people would you say and what
Evans happen at you
let me think it's it could have like the
I think the main we didn't have any
specific example that it talks all
generalities which makes it not the most
original whole original it make not
makes it the most original analysis to
me basically okay with you guys have
interviewed for like what four times
yeah yeah we were having a conversation
we who are you talking about like it
takes it takes you're noticing it takes
being around some pretty intense people
right to be able to keep your mind
stimulating and I got this sense of like
for the the full potential that's you to
come out yeah you need a lot like what's
salient to you needs to like have lots
of levels of intelligibility and
dynamics and purpose and yeah thank you
otherwise you're just kind of like your
brain needs that that to be to stay
awake non-redundant stimuli but the
potential what what do you see is like
if we turned up if we switched him all
of the switches on all the switches well
what's potential and what has you all
the switches yeah all the switches are
fun yeah yeah yeah Alexes have you ever
circled someone that bipolar mania if
they stayed yeah yeah totally
yeah I have been what do you think about
that that's an interesting one well
first of all I don't think circling is a
treatment for that disorder in any other
not enable the best out of people
yeah do you think that to the mania
state enables the best out of people
you know I have some clients right now
that are that that are hyper can go
hypomania and I've been with them and
those those states right I would say is
long because here's what's interesting
is I've noticed that people who are
hypomanic when they're manic they're
brilliant
like their milk walk out and no like
from one simple conversation that I
wouldn't even notice they'll hear like
the the God speaking to them right and
have this intricate lattice work of
meaning and connections and because they
see patterns everywhere however if it's
not connected to like if you follow it
all the way around if it's not connected
to reality right it's just inherently
yeah I know sometimes some people people
are very very well grounded in reality
it's just that for whatever reason
there's a lot of them aren't allowed
opportunity to be grounded reality if
they aren't allowed to have the true
have a fear of triple - fearlessly
experiment with all of their beliefs
about themselves and how the intervenes
the world and seems that they're
socialized out of out of like having the
most radical beliefs of of change
ability like I think one one common one
common false black color is as abstract
an excessively high agency it you see
really symmetrical thinking which have
then been and then the problem of the
people can't discuss those with anyone
or self-corrects with anyone and then
that's that's and because of this at
least who to the states would be
actually are bipolar manic where they
actually do things that are harmful and
often times and no one else's precedence
because they're just so scared
mmm-hmm yeah totally like I have a
friend just went through bipolar manic
episode and oh my god
[ __ ] it yeah yeah what would you example
spending spree if you think you because
oftentimes people manage me in mania
they they have a very strong desire to
correct to make sure to basically
relieve it really ever since frustrating
them or it relates it relieves here
there's a card sort of anxiety so
sometimes we do see they do seems like
the most expensive way of really
relieving they're exciting like they can
last me plane tickets or booking
Laughlin hotels or just anything to
basically get out of those internal self
restrictions
yeah yeah totally now we're the are work
when is it is that enough stimulation
for you being around somebody who's
hypomanic does that what does that bring
out most people who are hypomanic aren't
don't express mania around me yeah so I
have never yeah we should also talk
about it when it does get expressed in
its absolute best as well yeah so when a
lot of people can call flow yeah right
the deepest cognitive instincts when
we're just in that state of just chasing
after our North Star with no obfuscation
with no distraction with just hyper
focus yeah and so yeah that can that can
get triggered by all different types of
behaviors sometimes aloneness sometimes
when you're with people and the
conversation is you're feeling that that
point there was a moment when you
started asking you started asking you
they directed the attention towards
towards like asking a question about
like maybe the relationship between Alex
and I and I had to like I felt myself
like adjust to like be ready to address
otherwise I was like more you know kind
of like relaxing so and to be able to
actually tap deeper into one's own
physiology when things like that happen
and when we're at these extremes of our
own personality as well and be able to
self reflect on that yeah at the most
granular level that things like circling
things like yeah being vulnerable and
emotionally intelligent these are the
practices that even today fifty years
ago men weren't they didn't I didn't
have to know these things as much but
today it's like no men have to be
emotionally intelligent now there's like
a whole new role of yeah of development
that's actually happening and and
especially for like Gen Z kids that are
being born into the world right another
whole new role they're also having to
steward earth and be emotionally
intelligent and make financial success
so there's like now the burdens really I
so yeah yeah yeah yeah totally an
intercept activity is something in being
able to weave in the in and out of those
spaces it's um
that's like seems like it's becoming
more and more crucial but we get less
and less practice of it like with it I
we were talking a little bit about this
before
I think the introduction of actually I
think it started with the answering
machine and then texting and email and
all the different iterations of that was
for the answering machine basically if I
wanted to exchange information with you
I had to I had to call you write the
introduction of the answering machine
was the first time where you could kind
of like relay in some kind of immediate
way information without having to do the
awkward social dance called talking
which is filled with them beauty right
so and then that turned into texting and
you know and now you have people like
Alex who prefer texting right prefer
messaging over talking is that true out
generally I mean the optimal optimal
interface is where you do but we're able
to do pose at the same time where you're
where if you're talking it's been out
man who treats professor talk or it's
been or like if doing Adam at matok like
microexpression and real-time I have
expression about really sure that as
you're talking if all this to be
captured in City right now this would be
optimal so that you can serve back
reference and search and then field
build onto scene so it's accumulated
rather than repetetive it is yeah what
this is so with Alex there's been
moments where I've been wondering about
the because he has in the the deep like
eccentric behavior and that can
sometimes like penetrate the social
spheres in ways that like make of people
like like feel different
a lot different yeah and so I'm curious
when you've when you've identified
people that are behave slightly like
differently around like social norms and
stuff where do you like where do you see
that like what has been some of your
what have you seen within that man I
tell you what I see that more than I
ever would have even predicted that I
would see that because it's the people
that I've been around or introduced I
think just being in the Bay Area and
then being around the kinds of spaces
that how those spaces go are gonna be
the things that like determine what
happens in the entire world right and
I'm will I watch that happen really fast
so I actually don't know what to make of
it I found myself like mmm
I have found myself with people who are
alike that I've just come to find out
that they ended up they are ended up
being a level of smart and intelligent
and interesting like yeah in ways that
that I continually impressed by and I
also think that there's something to
there's something to not having you know
one of the things I hear from from a
like a lot in the rationalist community
right is they look at a lot of the like
a lot of the warmth that people consider
really good they look at and they see
these kind of like local optimizing and
they don't quite get it
mmm right they literally go like this
seems like a bunch of local optimizing
everybody's kind of lying to each other
right lying really yeah like what like
from their view because I think that
seems to be that they don't get the same
thing out of like a big let's say heart
connection oh they don't get all the
information for that right so they're
like okay we just talked about that okay
now how will this help us change the
world how well so it's like what's next
yeah versus being present with what just
happened yeah and finding that to be
really profound and impactful I I follow
sometimes I have a similar response to
some circling as well right so I can I
can resonate at that but I don't use the
word lying I think that's that's quite
ridiculous that's like their worldview
contrasting with yours like people are
different colors on the color wheel
somewhat I think world for both in that
palm is often times schedule a circling
right now people's there's an
appointment rather than as an as we be
seen I think the moments and people need
to certainly reflection on demand yeah
on demand circling if would be the types
that benefit T before like we're like
trending but remote all the time but
still have the moments where they would
where they would rather be prevent
except they can't predict those yeah I'm
curious with Alex specifically and with
people that are also height like really
eccentric I've seen now several times
where even my behavior as well I'm hyper
centric as well not quite as much as
Alex in some ways but what I've seen
with my own behavior is that my
eccentricity will help me achieve
certain vertical networking like I'm
like hardcore trying to like reach
people and and yeah that kind of stuff
and and then at the same time I want to
kind of stay with that for a second wide
why did you why did you just say that
yeah because of all the famous people
you've reached out to and that damn
network you have is with people I
thought even I let I can't reach or most
people I know can't [ __ ] reach
okay so now here's this is interesting
because the reason why I said exactly
what I said is because I'm curious in
terms of one's ability to find
themselves in their most self actualized
in self transcendence States I feel as
though having some degree of desire to
dive deeper into that like that really
granular emotional intelligence space
where we're not just kind of like
whatever Inc eccentric lee across the
world but that were like also able to
like take ourselves into a meta
perspective and be like how did I just
behave in that social situation and why
did that person just disconnect from me
because I think that can help a lot and
and I've this has happened to me so many
times Alex I know what's happened to you
as well but that the that when we can
I do make behavior that triggers people
to want to take a step back from us I
think it's important for us to be able
to really reflect on our own behavior
and think what is most optimal for my
own self actualization of transcendence
what is most optimal and for ya and for
others as well
yeah often times like I not only forgive
me that's a issue most I think people
who are like hi kindness and your super
reasonable are willing to give people
second chances except I don't think
there is a sort of product function for
challenge chance and week that we can
also can't absolutely abide by policy if
given second chance to everyone either
yeah yeah what do you think about guy
Alex hmm he's so I know he's in a
certain community which a lot I still
don't have very much optic level and a
knowledge of who he is maybe because
there's like a lot of sense of
information to its the disclosed
students are cleaning that he didn't
able to say and that's and because of
this it's like you're still like more of
a procedure or like I don't see that I
don't see say this the that intensely
intensely Club high kind of edginess
that I I finally optimal for my flow
basically okay but I mean I still
appreciate speaking with you but going
to know you're important for a lot I I
would also say that Alex you move so
fast that I think sometimes what gems
people have that could help you uh go
past you like you're either you may not
see the fit of those gems in your life
because you're moving so fast yeah yeah
and also because I I think medium
asymmetry because I'm a tax person I'm
an interested person and unfortunately
most people are not mm-hmm what does
that mean to be to be a text person or a
person I prefer email I prefer a mess
I prefer and seen the cumulative or it
just ways where you you know where we
where you can provide an extended
response and assert that where you don't
really think the first response but
rather are trying to accumulate
knowledge for entire history and for and
and you give give some time to have a
more solid experiences it's so that it
can't determine like optimal optimal fit
or like optimal communication mm-hmm
right right yeah for me what I'm what
I'm noticing is that there's constantly
and urge within me to like want to help
someone else like like in this case Alex
like potentially see some of the gems
yeah like slowing down and understanding
emotional intelligence more yeah yeah
how it could like help well I I don't
know if you like one of the things I
don't know I think it would be
presumptuous yeah I did to assume that
you could slow down okay or that that's
desirable yeah but like what happens in
yeah when you try to slow down like yeah
would it make sense yeah yeah
also yeah I could let's say hmm
yeah I'm just I'm imagining I'm
imagining that I'm getting the sense of
for example when I look at you and I
look at you versus when you look at him
and I look at him what you see I have a
feeling isn't necessarily the same thing
yeah right that's probably true but even
like a mom and a dad and their child
right you know yeah doing that close
yeah totally
mm-hmm I so I'm just I'm mostly I think
I'm mostly kind of I notice I'm kind of
a little bit back and like like kind of
like letting you unfold and just getting
a sense of like oh yeah you're like a
interesting human being then but you're
do you see things very very differently
versus versus the way we all see like a
coffee cups like pretty similar
yeah birth is another human is
completely different right so for
example when you're like I prefer multi
level perspectives tax ideally text and
yeah multi positions all at once
history streams transcript yet although
all those kinds of things edges of the
internet so there's so for example it
occurs for you is that's the most
optimal way to do it and that has it
just doesn't occur for me like that like
so I'm like huh there's some way that
you're viewing things differently than
me so I just wanted my I just had
somebody get interested
how do you see things you know well what
is it well what is I'm curious to know
what like what is the potential gray in
you and what do you see the potential in
him that if all of his switches were
unlocked right
all of your potential that like you want
to be around really stimulating people
because you come on board a lot more
like if you fully came on board what
like what's what do you think what's
potential in you
that's a good bread
is it is this you slow like kind of
consciously slowing down its level
trying to figure out what I should say
and yeah I know I'm underperforming real
tonight potentially I think most people
are for that matter - I think the rate
or level at which I'm underperforming
it's much much higher than level with
other people are underperforming it's
like also it's like a hole trying to
communicate true in the way that allows
me to be at my best and in terms of like
in terms of like affecting something
that makes it relevant long term or or
also affecting a sort of change that
also kind of like makes my ability of
high agency sustainable super high AUD
sustainable forever long possible
especially when especially in the future
if say like when now we have amazing
technology better technology than before
so it's like and we have the capacity to
basically like do we have computational
power we okay so it's real important
another we have company capacity now
that we don't have that we haven't had
in decades past which is real important
but sadly I think it seems like advanced
in society and people social essence
haven't kept up with this dance
competition
capability which is like the main reason
why most people in most part who are way
way way underperform forms or potential
right now right great
what what do you see like what has you
interview him four times like it seems
as though his switches are already
mostly on everyday like to almost their
fullest like I do think that when I was
not not all but I do think that went out
yeah when Alex says that most people
perform under their potential but alex
is closer to his potential I'm not close
with my potential no that is what you
just said early no I thought what I said
I said I said I think most people aren't
performing I think through the level
which I'm under performing it's much
lower than the level which most of you
prefer which is very similar to what I
just said okay yeah yeah okay so but ooh
point point is is that the way that like
if you take something like who you are
as your unique personality right now and
and you keep a road road running with
that you'll achieve whatever you you
know set out to do if you take something
along the way like a gem that someone
may be passing along to you that may be
helpful it may argument it may just
deter you potentially away from that so
I don't actually know what thing is here
this would be like for example me like
last night when I was asking you
questions about when how to become a
better interviewer because you've been
dishing me some feedback and like if I
took the gems that you were passing
along to me if I integrate them into my
essence and run with them it likely is
gonna help me a lot if I don't then I'll
likely deter me away from what the the
fullest potential could be so it's just
things like that so it's and it's it's
also this is apartment major part of
circle a just being with who he is
period and being with who you are period
without wanting to do things like hey
take these the speed back that I'm
delivering you and and see how it
affects your life yeah this is so yeah
these are the differences yeah totally
yeah between ways that people can engage
with each other right with if I'm if I'm
willing to just ask you know what about
you how do you look how do you behave
when all your switches are turned on you
say forward before we before do that so
I think I was just caught by
right when you were talking about like
when you when you brought up with them
yeah I think that if you were to slow
down there's like some gems in there but
you have to operate so fast what I
perceived actually was you were caring
about him your kitty was caring about
you like he was he's you could tell like
he's been tracking you he's noticed
patterns right he's got his eye on
something potential and you wants the
best for you and he was like so we
pointed that out right no because I
constantly rent RAM against you know
people was depressed read with me oh
this brief frustration it's not a sign
of the highest highs emergent
intelligence but rather I mean what the
point besides I often ran myself against
walls because I seem to I think you
practice the same ineffective strategies
and without being aware of them the
broader context is where in which some
some label are sub earnest but others
can label as maybe maybe I'm just trying
to get a world model across where the
problem of course because it's record
I'm more confident in fact every time
I'm saying it's going to actually going
to matter
whereas for do an interpretation in
person personal interaction and most of
the time in general it's just yes I've
told you fast most people can forget
everything I'm gonna forget most scenes
it's gonna it's a wreck but anyway yeah
it's like the thing I think the thing I
was like I felt I just realized this is
like I felt I think I assumed but it was
more like a feeling
mmm that's like oh he's caring about you
oh yeah I appreciate that
right it shows in a nun obvious way like
not in a way i immediately perceive it
as yeah totally totally now that I
pointed out and you perceive it like
what happens for you are you like I like
you caring about it's like it's had so
it's like people sometimes are picky
about how its received in other people
like mmm-hmm it but you have to like for
example that's why people are like
non-responsive to parent parental care
because people give the boy parents care
about you is not expressed in the ways
that they understand the best aunts
it's a forceful way to cue which causes
like adverse reaction or but on the
other hand you have to be aware even if
you're a rationalist or even if you
think worthless if your ass your
optimizing for your own it utility
function or something you have to you
have to be able to express a accept in
all ways and but still it like hard it's
just hard to express most people just
aren't don't have like in saying that
was super agility
some people have have higher loves
emotional agility like like some people
and some people they they're just they
get so much reward based on the purely
appearance you care about you perhaps
more than do it like if you're an
attractive girl for example care from
attractive girl seems to matter a lot
more than caring from someone who's who
doesn't seem to be who haven't been
optimized to basically express those
affectionate feelings as much even
though the tractors girl probably have
mailed to other people to let me care
about her do and like they probably
don't really care about you as deeply as
say someone who even that's good is
expressing it yeah yeah totally yeah you
have a high level I'm experiencing is
having a high level of when you respond
when you speak you take things any like
you put them in in language right and in
terms and as isn't data yeah really
really fast and things that I think I
just know by feeling it somehow like God
like without being as explicit something
I just know that good stuff yeah that's
good stuff no taking stuff from politics
with it yeah there's like a certain
level I think and this this has actually
come from just working with a lot of
people who it's like when you feel the
oneness and then you try and put it into
words
okay stuff oh yeah mmhmm yeah there's
just a sense of there's a certain kind
of like and I wonder about this like so
we were talking about autism before
right is it like because I heard autism
one of the things that it does is that
people who are autistic have less the
ability to to
toad cog NIH's it a certain level of
abstraction so they so they know
something through like a more of a
literalization that's what I've heard
and that that makes sense and I think
that there's ways in which there's ways
in which I notice I when I'm around
people like rationalist and stuff like
that who are who their IQ is like so
fast I don't I don't even think I can
like perceive of it I always like to
joke my akyüz low but it's big but the
but the the the sense that I think that
we do we do get hit with a level of
abstraction like oh you care about him I
can feel that right and then I can bring
it into alert like slowly bring it into
terms but one of the things that I one
of the things one of the things that I
I've noticed is that there's so it's so
it's so complicated social interactions
and social rules and all of those kinds
of things are being around people that
want to get good at that and abstract
out those rules and then enact those
rules like consciously
is its I'm impressed it's a lot of work
to do it's a lot of a lot of work to do
damn what you just said a little bit of
goes like such a major key that we don't
actually need to apply words to feelings
and so if we can tap deep into the
catalogue of feelings into subjective
feelings we can feel with other people
we don't need to put words on them
because you and I just look at each
other and we go mm-hmm right and then
from that moment it like even Alex and I
when you're like oh there was some care
there you know Alex and I were kind of
just like
and we had that moment too and those
like we don't need to be like well that
was because you said that we care about
each other and that's why we looked at
each other and we looked at each other
like we actually like recognized what
you said and that was really profound
for both of us like we didn't need to do
that whole stream of thought that huh
yeah went into space we just felt and
understood yeah and so Alex that can
actually be like a compression algorithm
feelings like understanding children
algorithm so like so like looking at
someone else in the eyes and feeling a
deep visceral love towards them and then
feeling that towards you that that
feeling right there catalogued is like
one of like the best like feelings for
most people yeah if it's believable
I tend to not surround myself with
people that yeah that make it feel like
it's not believable this is actually
this is actually the thing that I've I
hear a lot is is like that's what I was
saying about like I summarized is like
they said like yeah this seems like a
people's talking about like
intersubjectivity just seems like a lot
of local optimizing right and everybody
says yeah I think the more you open
about you are about yourself to the West
world's got the people's likes more than
know about you the more they know your
your entire histories dream the more
lovable you are to the non hater ish to
be able to see the best in you to impact
the future because I think a lot
everyone seems to be grown-ups around by
haters and criticism and they guardin
totally hit here is the prism which is
like so far it's been open which ones
reading fives helped so free to being
open about themselves to everyone else
who does why they contain everything and
self me and everything it's like we we
just we just raised you believe in it
believe that people don't really want
the best for us mm-hm
right well our social fabric needs to
change from the self dealing culture to
the inclusive fitness culture yeah
that's a that's a scale problem that
we've had from our family values not not
scaling mm-hm yeah right but this is
this is all changing where it feels as
though you can walk up to someone else
like again you're not you're really
trying to selectively curate the people
that you hang out with period but then
those people that you do meet even for
the first time in person or even they a
friend bring someone else and you give
them that really long warm hug and
you're looking at each other in the eyes
and you're like wow and what does care
mean that for some people it means
financial care for some people it means
the deep emotional care asking people
questions getting to know who they are
for other people it's it's all there's
all different ways of expressing care
and so yeah that's so which one of those
are all of them and
oh yeah if Leia like I don't expect
anything besides like your deepest
presence and love and and care like when
you're when you're here with me and and
and that good things are gonna come up
during that time
what are you hearing him say vice-like
expressing care in different ways and
what you what do you make of the of
those who wait when exactly is it means
you have like hair and it's like you
have to be like maximally the holy [ __ ]
I didn't remember what the read dreams I
had last night but anyways almost it's
also like there's also a distinct
difference between care and about
someone and say just enjoying the
presence there seems to be a difference
like yeah you control someone and
totally enjoy the presence or something
so hearing care about about mm-hm
about them internally internally and
even then you can care about someone
even if you care about somebody to you
you can care about someone without like
hearing about deeply about their entire
emotional state even though it's not
like here at the most mature form it's
important you like I think carrying one
can say the cane is a beautiful scene
irrespective of whether or not it's it
it is Memphis itself in the most
complete form of caring in all respects
even some forms of caring is being cared
about is far more important than then
none yeah yeah totally I think that's a
bit that's a big distinction about
enjoying your presence and and genuinely
if there's definitely different levels
of care right different levels of
importance oh yeah and also sometimes a
lot of people who do care about you
there's oftentimes care about whether or
not you integrate wells in a social
fabric which then like we do a really
huge fight between family members or
people who care about or concerned about
you this and this is like one of the
huge kids where I say there is or even
like people who care about gays and
whether or not they can socially within
the rest of society which then we lost
some what some call it's tough lot of in
which case caring can totally backfire
if carrot is
Co prevent with a sort Aryan traits but
anyways that's beside the point
um the point is I think there is like
our form of care that are nothing but
good and it feels amazing if you know
you have it let's ask Alex about what
are some of the deepest emotions that
you felt with yourself and with others
Oh
so yeah this is kind of sad because I'm
not
I have having a weird job I wasn't
having a weird develop jet history as
I've had I'd love to have super super
close friends but I'm not super close
with anyone and I think I started oh
come with me is missing because I
haven't had that experience even though
I totally want it yeah I feel similarly
yeah how do you how do you know that you
want it oh because I know I know what
the feeling feels like I can describe
any words later just I've had I've
almost has experiences people with
people when I was really really young
like oh my god let's be friends let's
let's explore the world you get it let's
live our worlds in their hands
yeah and then you definitely have a
sense when when you're searching you're
14 years old and you meet others other
say people of the same age who are just
whose entire worlds and head of them and
you just want all the toys to be shared
with them and you want to tell
everything to them you just want to
share their entire life hit with them
yeah and I've had experiences them with
I've their moments of my life where I
kind of had that experience of them but
then something fell apart and then it's
hard if you recreate a little bit later
on sadly right so you've that you've
experienced those feelings before yeah
and it has become it's become more like
it sounds like it's it was more common
when you were younger and less as you
get older right do you know why do you
have a sense of way part of it is I
think most people don't have that sense
of a limited time or unlimited
possibility II especially when they get
trapped and so when they trade you're
trapped with a desire to lights a signal
like even even even though I got trapped
or the stupid signalling phenomena where
I had to like get the highest I where I
had you like stuff cities many pieces
possible or [ __ ] like that or get the
highest
subject I think he's subject as possible
or in that that's just like experience
where you just hide your some other
people in order to get the high score or
get give high straights possible that
all sometimes you like close yourself
off it's like you you are from from
let's say truly meaningful amazing
really inhibit friendships and I think a
lot of people also send I feel like I'm
turning out in the sense and it's a
certain point where it happens to
everyone and basically like not the
sense of presence just isn't there which
one do we optimize for certain people
optimize for doing the super connecting
and generalizing their network like that
other people go deep into just three
people and feel the really deep emotions
that just three people so totally yeah
grab this truck I just dropped by that
like like I think you said yeah it's
kind of a little sad yeah yes you want
something and it's not and it's not
there oh yeah I totally nabel's the best
book I was like I know people that my
from a little talk was like how love is
like an energizer
it's energizes you in a way that very
few of your emotions do it makes you at
your best
yeah that's a good one I know I know
being married is like I'm strong I'm
shocked at like how much being married
is actually affected me like my whole
and how its how its effect not just the
experience of the relationship but what
having that solid in the background yeah
has done to the way I operate in the
world right yes really intense and I
think this starts to get into things
about attachment right like what their
understanding I think they can even
measure it now right like the the like
the biology of the way human beings
attached to one another and this whole
notion of of that when you have people
that you know without a doubt care about
you right that that if I come to you and
distress right you will reassure me even
above and beyond what you feel about my
immediate state of being in that moment
even if it's offensive to you there's if
I get that you
care about me unconditionally no matter
what and you have one or two of those
relationships in the background there's
a way in which you can kind of like I've
noticed this for myself there's a way in
which I can open up to the more and more
Ambu 'ti I can tolerate more more
ambiguity in the world because there's
this sense of like in the background
yeah I know what you mean yeah yeah I
don't have that confidence why I'm so
[ __ ] erotic still for example yeah
sooo then it's almost as though
attachment to an unconditional love
gives us the ability to pursue and
browse the world we live in more freely
or with a different level of the
security and intensity than potentially
if we didn't have a pillar of
unconditional love behind us that that
yeah where where where was it for you
that was not there expecting love from
the wrong people and burning out I'll
heavily on them getting myself too
attached to the first smart people I
knew when they weren't really wholesome
and this is a problem everyone has
growing up because everyone it's not
surrounded by the people that they
should become themselves with and it's
just also times when your classmates
from middle school how sometimes people
are like why the [ __ ] are we friends to
each other especially after the discover
new people outside of their school that
it's yeah where you think where you
think it's like that that the connection
is a genuine you and me when it actually
is context dependent
yeah right leave that and then that
could be a really kind of disheartening
like break yeah I don't know one thing
that that I'm very formal so early in
his part of the university Washington it
produces it allows the very strong
friendships or at least for a while
there's some of us but on the other hand
it's it's a it's a very intense
experience it happens you it's such an
eloquent in life and it's like I've seen
some of the amazing friendships come out
of it but I also noticed that they're
not as how the deepest friendships
relationships especially like if you
said lock for
then make high-performance it also liked
em to select against a developed being
more wholesome I think like the earliest
pertinent you got have so much potential
but they could like use more circling in
it or just more emotional intelligence
awareness because it's like I think it's
one of the true gems of the world in
some ways mm-hmm what's that I want to
make sure you get what ya can what's the
true gem of the world really into pro
competing for Washington yeah yeah early
early entrance program where you enter
college early entry yeah we're inter
college like age 14 or 15 yeah yeah
god I would I just think that that's a
whole what you're talking about like
that level of intelligence so early on
where you're an urine let you're in a
context that like with people there's so
much older than you are that's just got
a happy its own a ride right people
think it is think people imagine this
more than that actually it's a case okay
yeah I must be one of them and muster
yeah yeah I think I just noticed that as
you're as we're talking about like this
place where it's like oh yeah you want
something and it's been hard for you to
have it and it seems like one of the
best things in the world right and you
struggle with having that to some degree
now like I just noticed I feel like I
feel that care feeling for you right
like there's a sense of just like I'll
be your best friend like but you feel it
with a lot of other people and that and
I think a lot of people feel frustrated
with you sometimes because they know
you're there for them but they also know
that you're all out there scattered
across so many other people they can't
just you you just can't be there for
them all the time unless you you
replicated 100 copies of yourself
yeah totally I'm working on that working
on that yeah yeah it yeah there's a way
there's a way in which there is a way in
which there is something distinct about
and this is how people experience
families a lot where actually their
family is not somebody that they would
like hang out with or necessarily enjoy
each other's company but there's a sense
of like where they know that if things
went south their family would be there
yeah right there's that level of there's
that level of like understanding or bond
and unfortunately I think it a lot of
families they think what is possible is
to have more of like the authentic like
emotional connection to at the same time
but I so for example like being like for
example if I was like alright let's be
best friends like what would what would
what I lied I enjoyed your smile what
would be like would there be anything in
the way of that you think oh man I
remember this the first time when I was
playing I asked someone let's be friends
and that's like in 11 years old I I used
to say this to all people like a lot of
the time I put playing like page of my
prayers - and they just whenever at
someone's lifting team with me and I
just add I just and I just had with my
friends lift and it's like they can't be
friends and oh my god I actually really
appreciate some of the friendships that
form that says oh that's that making the
table request other people have to think
team team with that look the most
natural organic way to make friends
right right
totally totally yeah my agent first
place in Paris two days were like so
format if I consider those to be the
most important literally one of the most
weird things you have haven't ever
happen ever to me this government agent
/ - yeah
discoveries the last thing age one of
the most important things you have ever
ever to have - my wife and I sell it to
everyone flat to their face it's a super
yes fine yes yes it's important it's
late discovering poor or Peter teal on a
level of importance huh a lot of people
mention that early video game days were
very important for them
yeah oh you all know this yeah man [ __ ]
boomers that go on great older people
that didn't grow up playing video games
so they don't necessarily yes and catch
this a new drift right yeah right and
another part of this that I think's so
interesting for me at least is that I
just feel as though so much of
conversation that happens in these
chairs especially this conversation has
been so heady so like intellectual even
though we were talking about
unconditional love was like so
intellectualizing it like we weren't
really like dropping in much
throughout this conversation into the
things that like guy does all the time
when he circles with people and
sometimes when we feature different
people here that we drop in more
emotionally into what's present and
what's happening yeah dropping a more
emotion I'd love to experience that so
for me for me I think I just did a
little bit of where what is steering
about like Oh like you want there's
something that you want in your life
that's like you have a hard time finding
and you feel sad about it like I just
felt yeah that was a big one for me too
I just felt like I had a major gratitude
for my mom and my uncle and Ron yeah
yeah oh I love your gratitude I really
appreciate your gratitude a lot yeah but
yeah I love them people talk about the
parents and their formative experiences
of parents and how much their parents
mean to them as long as say the parents
also don't hold them back from higher
optionality yeah yeah I see like I feel
your emotions in your face anyway yeah
like I'm actually expressive emotionally
like moments where it seems like a pre
like a pre reflective or an involuntary
so Kylie wait what if they cure you
something like that I'm not exactly I
don't
I got a saying I don't even know what
autism yeah yeah it's just the
neurodiversity is raw with him it's like
yeah like I said when we first saw each
other again today is that Alex has the
most like under-represented character
archetype in the video game of
civilization yes so few people have his
personality traits in the game and so
that's what makes it very exciting I
think and I think we need to be very
careful with like the way that we like
put words about people on to them
because then that then that yeah bit
cautious about very very cautious yeah I
would yeah it's like way better to just
be like a hella unique like I love this
yeah the character and yeah like that
kind of oh yeah I love the praise it's
often times they really appreciate it
whether the praise translates to care on
the long-term is a different scene and I
think people can be better maintaining
the sense of caring that comes from
praise and maybe not seeking out praise
for its own sake but also like I like
you can pray celeb
all the time but sometimes people
celebrities ends up being prey for shady
people in the long run huh print what is
your like the praise like how do you
experience the pro yeah what's amazing
at the moment it used to be I used to
see that type of praise like like you
know those people who make some news
winning some academic award or for doing
something beastly like sending 22 ApS or
something else similarly extreme that
show that they're superhuman or beyond
so that they're superhuman or beyond
everyone else that's the type of
creative I saw it for and I thought for
in the wrong place that tromelin if
myself thinking it for it even though i
acting though it's actually easy to do
this simply than other people simply but
i like producing yourself at you're out
max after noobests and not necessarily
do going by predefined scenes like
[ __ ] college for tests or whatever
even though i yeah I admit I [ __ ]
love the College Board in a lot of ways
it's yeah pecan mmm-hmm can we go deeper
into just like Alex and his switches and
the unconditional love and just like I
want to see if Alex can be can we like
drop into his heart in his gut yeah well
one of the things I think I'm kind of
I'm realizing is like I that I noticed
I'm like well I don't to say cautious
but I'm just I'm just aware of like what
even dropping into your heart means for
you right like how we would know I the
one of the things that I'm just kind of
picking up a little bit is that there's
that it seems like when you're when
you're feeling something it seems like I
can feel it and you're still you're
still talking just as fast but there's
an animation there's like that there is
up to at that that I something gets
communicated
- emotive through facial expression and
but then it's moving as fast as
everything else worse but it maybe
lingers a little bit longer and makes me
it just says it has me just get more
interested in you and me - there's like
a feeling of adoring almost maybe
something like that seems a little
minimizing it's not exactly how I
that could come across as minimizing
it's not it's not that there's just like
I feel the same adore or Dora shouldn't
what you said when the people in your
school ray you thought they were good
they were wholesome and they wore like
you like you bought it I think they're
wholesome I I bonded over over them
being impressive in certain their
domains I think I still seek to G
factors like the most important scene
but it just G factor the yeah the G
factor meaning the general intelligence
general intelligence yes and that
incorporates which aspects of
intelligence it incorporates it's like
the see that correlates most with all
aspects of intelligence so now I believe
that like does that include IQ and EQ it
includes both IQ EQ yeah and what other
things does it include but on the other
hand its IQ I think IQ does show IQ huge
have each what's the highest level to
cars generally very high IQ so you'd be
a dog until like be super attentive
emotionally weights and most people are
not conscientiousness is another aspect
of general intelligence you want one's
ability to follow through on things that
they say that they're gonna do I think
that's actually that's complete that
that's or that totally are talking to a
true general intelligence in the German
population
yeah is that the thing the thing was
first thing I thought it was the second
greatest what what I was gonna say is
like I was almost district you ready to
say it before we asked about the the G
word yeah yeah go ahead
was was actually I was like oh yeah like
what I what I'm getting about you is
you're good like you're good like you're
I just get this this kind of Gestalt
sense of like oh yeah you're I don't I
don't doubt you're like doubt your
intentions like I can I can tell I can
somehow pick up just your sense of like
you're gonna do you'll care about people
you'll be responsible I guess all the
things that you said about just about
general intelligence but I think I was
kind of like overwhelmed with
overwhelmed with a sense of that or a
recognition of that like I was like I
could totally see becoming really good
friends with you yeah
what we're also all good and yeah and
evil that it's not Oh totally
yeah totally and I'd where's Alex's
shadow mm-hmm do we know does Alex know
I'm impatient mm-hmm yeah yeah I'm sure
we'd find out give it enough time we'd
find out like for you like you've been
getting that it sounds like you you guys
you guys have a relationship
well you guys have like you've
interviewed four times you've got leave
yeah what's it what's your experience of
like your relationship with with him do
you feel close closer to him over time
yeah yeah closer over time for sure yeah
uh-huh
yeah what about you what's your
experience of him yeah I I really
appreciate you a lot yeah and it was
amazing being with you in a few
and uh I think I have to get to know you
better or more but yeah yeah what's the
part that like that was like oh yeah
there's like I could I could get to know
you more
yeah what what do you have a sense of
like what it is that you don't quite
know about him yet or is there is there
someplace where there's like hesitation
or that you don't quite understand or
like what's your
or that sense of just like oh yeah we
haven't spent enough time there for my
nervous system isn't totally relaxed
around you or do you have a sense of it
me nothing with towards them yeah just
in terms of like we have very very
different social API for most people and
they think this limits closeness so as
most people I've discovered social
social what's that maybe like the social
algorithm says okay structures that Alex
uses when he interacts with people are
are different the protocols and I have a
high degree of open-mindedness towards
like what Alex is period and every time
that I hang out with them I learn more
and more about him and it's very fun
it's just that there is something about
a there's something about a world that
that is seemingly heading towards
excessive self dealing rather than the
global can fitness that we so need of
like inclusive studio I seem excessive
self dealing no no no not not saying
that because no no no Alex not saying
that because of you but just that in
general it's becoming it's becoming
quite hard to figure out like what
people are about at their deepest
essence and like how much they really
care about just letting go of their own
ego and just doing things on behalf of
like upgrading the world around them and
just you know being cool with just
passing after that now it just seems as
though it's like everything's like super
like anti-aging let me live forever let
me make trillions of dollars let me it's
just like it's going kind of craziness
in that direction so anyway maybe that's
some sort of a projection from me of the
way that I see some of the civilizations
true direction but on a more intimate
like personal level when you become a
super connector when you're super
connected to like hundreds of people
you're not intimately connected with
three let's say and that ability to dive
deep into like an unconditional love
with one person like being able to like
call someone and be like hey I need to
talk like really deeply about my
feelings or hey I need five hundred
bucks or hey like will you come and help
me move or whatever those things are
like they're just not as a readily
present because of the self dealing
social fabric so right yeah yeah these
are all so intertwined
well it's if there's something about
like whether this kind of insight a
couple of months ago if you ever seen
you seemed play part it was just really
nice when you do the soundtrack Rick
Rick I've watched Braveheart I don't
know ten times or something you know my
like grew up with Braveheart
but I'd never heard the soundtrack yeah
you know the love of the princess on
track I grew up listening to that oh
yeah why do you bring up the pre-fight
contract well I had this experience of
like where some a friend of mine played
it and it we were on a road trip and he
just played it in his car and I was like
whoa what is this thing it's like
there's a soundtrack and it just brought
me right there with all the emotions
mm-hmm but I got done with that night I
I got done listening to it and I was
like you know what I don't even think I
ever even noticed the soundtrack during
the movie right yeah yeah it's so
interesting so it's like kind of like
here because what a sound trend is how
didn't we start thinking about what a
soundtrack does is that when it works it
disappears right like it's to the degree
that it's not you don't hear it
explicitly that it
it kind of brings the past in the future
into that moment and consolidates the
mood of the movie and I was thinking
about like well what would happen if
like what would if you watch watch the
movie with without the soundtrack great
or you played Metallica in the
background right are you making an
analogy to life yeah maybe
ecology actually the relationships
relation whereas whereas they think it's
like something about you know I think we
do have a soundtrack we have a
background like Gestalt sense right that
with a song played at the right time
yeah totally I think it's Ronnie's phone
right right now though that was the
soundtrack of my movie yeah but the this
sense of it just a sense that even when
I'm not thinking about it right what has
that cup show up in the way that it does
there's this background horizons that
are kind of like a soundtrack and I
think for us I bet I bet what determines
the soundtrack playing in your
background in my background in each
other's background is actually our the
background of our relatedness with other
people right so it's like if if I'm
estranged from my family right and I'm
gonna fight with my family and I'll be
at work and doing some menial tasks and
even when I'm not thinking about those
relationships on some level that sound
it alters the soundtrack in the
background tonight I have this sense of
just working with people of that I've
started to track that I think people
when people have a sense that that
they're cared about right that there
that there are people that are walking
around that if you went missing a couple
of days they would notice or you know
that people care about that you care
about you know like what you care about
in your life that it's not even a care
about the same thing but they cared that
you care about things and you have that
sense of those relationships in your
life it's something that you don't leave
home without right I think it is like
kind of like the soundtrack in the movie
that disappears whether or not you're
thinking about it or not so that's the
sense I get of like where I'm
kind of piecing together just why I felt
so kind of moved right when you said and
sad and wanting for you right about that
I was just like I was like oh I felt I
almost like it hurt the soundtrack in
the background came forward for a moment
yeah that's a great way to put it
do you often room in a few songs in the
background of your life you offer
gurmann a few songs in the background of
your life like Reuben ate my house yeah
I don't know what you mean by Reuben is
like you often daydream songs in your
life hmm you know at some level I think
what I do is like I've made a prophetic
a living off of hearing the the
background songs every final fantasy
yeah yeah like what a while ago okay
yeah songs are like intense yeah they're
very intense totally but but just it's
just interesting to me of going all of
like that's the way that we that's how
we organize what shows up as saline in
the foreground are these background
horizons of what is or isn't possible
and like mmm how the relationships in my
life are they they disappear just like
the soundtrack does and but they show up
and all of my immediate what becomes
salient for me yeah yeah right
and I just yeah this is kind of like
felt I think just closer to you and I'm
like I want I keep finding myself and
having like a sense of Abinadi oh where
I think it's something like something
like I'm I feel more in touch with that
you care about do you care about things
in your life right like that you just a
sense of it you know and yet you're
really different but there's something
about that difference does it feel it
feels like that difference like kind of
has something come closer and me with
you
hmm what's that what's that feeling
maybe I'll in later yeah
is it but is if it is a feeling as I'm
reading that correctly yeah
see there's a quality of like how just
that you just did that tells me like
what that communicates to me is just an
openness and I think there's that
quality of like when I when I say the
word good like it is good like just that
impulse to come grab my hand it seems
good to me touches my heart
well
how's it for you I think this is the
spate that kind of feeling space that
you're wanting it's beautiful yeah yeah
affection looks like it anymore what
about for you that was a really
beautiful this guy this guy's this guy's
the feeler man was great yeah that was
so wonderful yeah yeah just being able
to be with you too connecting like that
was really nice yeah yeah for what do
you mean by nice like nice like it was
human it was really deeply human and I
think we're so disconnected from being
deeply human yeah
we're disconnected from our source from
where we get all our nourishment from
our planet yeah we're disconnected from
each other at unprecedented levels with
our news feeds right it's all stacking
up in in ways that are exacerbated by
information technology and and but I t's
also doing good things like connecting
us around the world there's some there's
a lot of nuance to this but totally I'm
I miss like when people sit across from
each other and then it's all like debate
debate debate head head head head head
head head head like that's like crazy
now like compared to being grounded and
like sitting next to someone and being
like you know we are just human and
let's drop in and realize how
interconnected we are and how important
like let's try and find rather than try
and argue our way and win let's try and
find something that maybe we can agree
on by maybe steel Manning each other's
arguments and finding yeah that's such a
beautiful scene I will admit though in
like when when the competition and the
drive to like to create your might
happens and like say low resource
environments where or where they're too
many people for for other reasons that
exist and yeah that's intense Alex yeah
it's it's like the cuckoo contra I think
the true contrasting forces exist
because even though we would love to be
in an environment of abundance and in
many ways certain people are it's also
the case that we that because the
attention of some he was limited and
especially those who get everything
then there is there is a true force of
scarcity that does seem to act on people
especially because we're not even sure
of the pop the plant can support this
many people that's alone yes yeah yeah I
noticed I want I just want people to be
able to know whether or not they're in
an I it relationship or an i thou lie
thou Heidegger yeah it's like that's
Boober it's more Boober it's Hyder
proper oh yeah like this in Boober would
say that Bieber yeah Martin Buber he's a
Jewish philosopher theologian
existential okay but he would say that
you know existentially we are in one of
two relationships all the time we're
either in the way he puts it like we
read there in an I bow or an i yet and I
it is basically where I see whatever it
is I'm porting you in this case as a
means to my own end
he said the up there's an i that arises
with it and there's an I that arises
with thou that there always spoken as
one word is II with is you would say it
and I think the thing that I worry about
right is that it seems like and I think
I think this has something to do with
technology it probably also has a bunch
of other things to do with it
like what every machine where you
started us yeah a little bit ago yet you
totally like where where I want people
to be able to not drop I it right you
gotta [ __ ] you have to function you have
to like instrumentalize each other and
see you know especially if you're doing
companies and strategies and all that
but I want people to be able to know
when they're in one or the other
mm-hmm right awareness yeah the other
yeah yeah because I think that I have a
feeling that it's becoming increasingly
more rare right that people even know
that there's such a thing is like an i
thou personal encounter right it's so
they're they're not even they don't even
know it's missing right because it's
like when things break down when you're
going when you're going like you have
some goal and inevitably you have stuff
that comes up and then people's emotions
get put into play and if you can't have
an environment where you can stop and go
oh wait a minute you're being affected
by this and that and be able to show you
that I cuz that's a thing of like
wait a minute something matters to you
let's kind of pause you like you can
like be able to go into that space and
start to tolerate the I that that arises
without right and be able to know that
distinction I remember it I remember it
as it seemed when I was younger like
that this is why I think has something
to do with technology right is that when
I was younger I remember that it just it
was like a lot more of those
interactions and or just in the day to
day life and it seems seems to me that
is we're sublimating so many things that
aren't about this ambiguity filled
embodied experience that that we're now
having people that don't look actually
ever have the experience of that and I I
just got it I have to think about the
agreed yeah ii think you know the impact
of that I just don't know what it is you
know yeah the potentially the
exponential technology error has driven
us more towards the I it rather than the
I though and I feel like Alex's
potentially you know maybe his
disconnection from part of that that the
last couple of thoughts has something
maybe to do with the level of like
dis disconnection from this specific
topic and wanting to maybe move on to so
yeah it's a to other things yeah yeah
and so so uh just from from me like from
what you just said I'm so aligned with
what you said like we need to discern
between the ayat and the I vow we need
to have the awareness to discern between
those and to develop that through skills
like circling deep like emotional
practice to discern between those yeah
but so simultaneously having yeah
strategy you know having still I it's to
be able to have strategy in life and
yeah with each other but yeah also on on
and on and on and on an input stream
like over life Alex brought up a little
bit ago also just that like people still
live in some scarce environments and
that's like a real thing
and like that's like competition
involved that's like putting people
other people down the valve that's why
people are so addicted should say
watching people own other people or
people just dominate other people rather
than people couldn't act essentially
connect with other people oh they're
looking for opportunity pre nothing but
down rather than upload to other people
and it's hard when people have evolved
in recent scarcity environments and yeah
yeah because it's hard when you you
actually have to get behind the eyes of
humans that have to live in like three
meter by three meter boxes on top of
each other and next to each other that
barely have water and food and then you
[ __ ] get it then you get the scarcity
mm-hmm and we have so much abundance
that we're not evenly distributing more
evenly distributing around the planet
yet and these are things that we talk
about a lot and that we talk to people
that are making the ah of the
augmentations in civilization to make
that transition happen any like wrapping
thoughts from you guys any thoughts on
the way out doesn't it like it's not
green it sounds good yeah yeah alex is
sitting in the Sun now yeah I may be
more aware of that more in the song
redhead a little bit I don't have hair
I'm I'm red so I may walk out of this
more pink that I'm comfortable with yeah
yes I like I like how much we we dived
into just that there's like a deep need
for more emotional yeah connection in
our world and a deeper discernment for
what's happening with like our
unconditional love their history as well
as like I really appreciate you your
soundtrack in the life that's happening
yeah I like that a lot
okay let's what's around you cool yeah
okay let's look in this do you want me
to read it right now yeah sure yeah
request for conversation counselling can
I say who's from yeah just delta-t mean
just just requester okay hi Alex I came
across your profile on Quora and watched
some of your talks on simulation on
YouTube I'm a 21 year old male who is
unsure of which direction to invest my
potential in which path to take in life
I would really appreciate having the
opportunity to talk to an intelligent
mind such as yours this is not an
attempt at flattery I'm just trying to
emphasize the reason for my interest as
soon as possible a phone call would be
preferred please let me know what time
maybe
for you Wow Wow
that's that's a big deal yeah so 21 year
old male who's unsure of which direction
to invest potential in which path to
take in life this is a big deal so
because humans want to know where to
direct for because humans are Forks many
and many times when they're young like
21 they have someone like can they reach
out to Alex can Alex maybe give them
some good mentorship advice that can
help rocket their trajectory in a
direction that is more better for their
actualization I enjoyed your smile oh
yeah like when that can't what is that
what's that mean to you just getting
that email yes good beautiful hmm it's
hard to say at the moment I think it's
good I'm still unsure I'm like I'm phone
calls not my my phone calls like not my
preferred mode direction at all so it's
like I still like I still really
wouldn't you know probably want you to
its back and I seen Keith if he seemed
to be really really seeking something
and I think if someone really really
seek believes himself that wants to seek
something I think it should be that I
think he just really really want
something we shouldn't analysis in him
and maybe this could like be the way to
unleash the potential in him I'm so I
just I think I really want to help him
in this I'm of course I don't know who
yes so and how does one open up the
bandwidth to be able to handle these
types of yeah yeah emails because what
if Alex's input stream is constrained to
wanting to learn other stuff that day
yeah yeah and so how do we pass along
people like this - yes did it passing
people how long is super important
should we give I'm not something to pass
people along and this is gonna be put in
the future I'm curious was that talking
with him not without having a madam just
reading that well what would you say do
you have anything that you would just
say I think I'm open
there there there are so there there's a
range of possible good the person could
be so it could be huge yeah yeah totally
so you'd have to you'd actually have to
talk with them I mean I know then and 21
this person could be pursuing so many
different paths in life and so for Alex
also it's a lot of pressure for someone
like Alex to - it's like both outs with
you
say it's both rewarding to be viewed as
someone that can help but also a lot of
pressure to help I don't feel super high
a super deep emotion inside of them it's
about it mm-hmm
and why did you show it to us I think
was very timely yeah total like we were
literally on the show that means quite
it's really cool you're doing like
you're definitely doing something right
if you're getting communications like
that as I think having like if you if
lots happening it's an exact coincidence
happen more often and even though
because it's like a project of magical
thinking and I think if people see it
closest happen more quickly more
frequently more quickly it give it a
sense of meanness to them which
motivates them that's good I like that a
lot
yeah yeah yeah Alex showed a coincidence
happening because he was you know on the
show again talking about things that he
found interesting other people were
watching reaching out this type of thing
if they mention simulation which is
exactly why I showed it because we're
literally on the show again and so I
think what Alex also is really pointing
out here is that coincidence people know
what some people haven't included what
the features gonna be like and they
watch it be part of the future and the
problem is that all the people that
visit surrounded by all those all the
stupid k12 signaling it's preventing
them from realizing that really from
Trent develops a narrative of how they
can be part of the future yeah how they
can shape the future how they can be
relevant in the future and there's like
a common here any along who want and if
we can acknowledge the people who have
this yearning we can get we could maybe
better cordon actually reach this you
heard that yearning people have a
yearning to be relevant that's one of
his big things to raise a beautiful
because people do like we yearn for that
unconditional love we yearn to be
relevant yeah
in a highly exponential technology
developing world how do we stay relevant
right right
totally and so unschooling doing a lot
of things that Alex believes in with the
K through 12 system and how it's not
helping advance a lot of people's yeah
potential yeah that that's a big way to
stay relevant as if you have influences
when you're four years old that you're
able to pursue things that interest you
rather than what a boxed system yeah
it's all it's all because it's it's all
basically test scores and yeah even the
people who are seen as doing their own
scenes as they're still the news
articles on them when people report
about some teenage prodigy is a yearly
report in people who are teenage
prodigies are long start from dimensions
they're certain axis such as self same
28-piece or being a teal fellow or just
doing something doing something that the
celibate academic excellence over
essence essence essence II basically or
just being impressive for the sake of be
or just yeah
yeah I mean I personally I owe my life
to some teachers yeah yeah of that but
that quality of of somebody see
something in me that no one else was
seeing in fact on all the regular test
scores like I always yeah yeah yeah that
type is so inspiring and also like so
profoundly rare most people do not get
this type of inspiration that's one of
the things to recognize you have a
talents and actors that are giving from
your own or the ones that you
traditionally measure well performing
low on a test score well let's see what
else you're really passionate about
uniquely well and the test for actually
matters like you know so this kid friend
of an Alexandra and Lacey she posted
some giftedness artisan low consoie
about about say people like criticizing
her for for like really saying that
she's so she they know he's good and yet
why isn't he doing as well as say they
sing she issues she found Mike he was
like I think she's one of the most point
people I ever met because she likes me
honestly on my past and she's like this
kind of she has weird background she's
for someone went to Sparky it's like the
weirdest background of anyone but that's
but that's so pursue be valuable like
your foul system is one of
I've ever seen yeah totally and it but
if that if no one sees that yeah right
like they people need to get that
reflection of be seen and be have the
experience of being valued yeah and I
think that's one of the big things that
like we train when we're circling it's
it's it's that kind of listening where
you actually can kind of feel into like
what's unique about that person and
respond to it right to a point where
they can actually come into being yeah
love to talk to him I also like I know I
have to offload this to b-boy noé in the
long road but I also I'm not sure if
there's anyone else in my network who
would be whose light would be who I
would be good at awful this true at the
moment especially because if they reach
out to me it means that they probably
feel an emotional connection to me that
they wouldn't feel if you're someone
like awful awful other than Chu of
course I think the task of offloading
people to other people is a very common
scene if you're a say if you're ready no
direction it's enough you pretty much
have no choice but you offload yeah
right right yeah this this is I think
this has been so good yeah yeah yeah
like I know people who advice teal
fellows who we like I pray those people
all the time but I also recognize that I
can't send it one network to those who
have I feel fellows yeah this is one of
those these are the things like we
talked yeah I want a knowledge graph
immediately afterward of this episode to
me a really easy horse yeah the key
things that were discussed
so we'll eventually get to that point
yeah all right
good stuff yeah yeah I'll give you guys
each home's proper out huge huge shout
out to everyone that tuned in and
watched we greatly appreciated love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
episode let us know what you're thinking
also we would love for you to check out
the links in the bio to simulation help
support us help us grow help us prosper
help us continue
impacting more people and also support
circlings with guys support Alex
kei-chan as well their links are below
and also you know take some of the
thoughts that we were talking about in
this episode and you can share them with
your friends your family coworkers
people online social media talking more
about topics like these and that's it
everyone much love thanks Ron
for being back there we appreciate it
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thanks for tuning and we'll see you soon
peace that's it
[Music]